bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on est
très flattée évidemment de vous recevoir
vie vous êtes un énorme producteurs vous
aussi tarak traque vous êtes l'héritier
de la dynastie ben ammar qui a longtemps
été associé c'est sarah que j'avais star
ac' bénin qui a longtemps été associé
aux destinées de l'état tunisien vous
est le neveu de l'épousé de bourguiba
vous avez commencé après études à rome
comme comme assistant de production
le matin vous vous levier pour aller
voir si les le plein des voitures était
fait quoi vous êtes vraiment commencer
en bas ensuite j'avais emmené d'orge
lukasz en tunisie georges locas pour la
guerre des étoiles il n'avait pas
d'argent et je disais oui à tous les
metteurs en scène de quelle que soit
leur nationalité
une tunisie encore pauvre et qui était
rentré dans le monde de tourisme et je
rencontre georges occase en aéroport et
il me dit est ce que tu as un décor pour
une planète toute manière je disais oui
par principe qu ils n ont eu qu une fois
qu'ils étaient là je me démerde ai
trouvé un accord et la planète de la
guerre des étoiles le premier je vous
parle dire exactement 30 ans je les
remets dans un village qui s'appelle
tataouine ray et la planète tatooine
pour les milliards de fans c'est un
petit village dans le sud tunisien qui a
beaucoup plu à giorgio cassin et depuis
georges ou castres vient tourner mais
même plan parce que ça lui porte bonheur
il vient tourner tous les plans de la
guerre des étoiles de la planète
tataouine
même s'il fait le film ailleurs comme ça
a été le cas l'an dia
mais l'histoire ensuite tu raques j'ai
beaucoup donné avec avec jésus vous avez
produit jésus de nazareth de zeffirelli
la vie de brian des monty python 13h45
avant jésus-christ de jean yanne et vous
avez distribué le film de mel gibson la
passion du christ j'ai vu aussi des
échecs vous savez du pirate de polanski
qui est une catastrophe pour vous vous
avez perdu combien tarak là dessus au
bain 20 25 millions de dollars presque
autant que moi un peu moins voulait
rentrer dans les toilettes
mais je les ai récupérées ouais grâce à
un procès historique c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire du cinéma qu'un
producteur étranger de surcroît du
tiers-monde
j'ai fait un procès à la grande major
company universal arrêt qui a duré dix
ans et j'ai gagné parce qu'il m'avait
signé un contrat qui n'ont pas respecté
c'est pour ça que j'ai perdu de l'argent
et preuve de la grande démocratie
américaine
j'ai gagné devant un jury populaire
19 millions de dollars bravo très
réussie avec la télévision où vous êtes
associé de berlusconi avec murdoch avec
patrick le lay et tf1 le cinéma vous
êtes associé à l'exil au dollar en tice
maintenant avec les frères weinstein
dans leur nouvelle société qui l'ont
créée après leur départ de miramax
alors vous avez vous êtes l'un des deux
frères weinstein légendes d'hollywood
producteur et distributeur alors
allons-y de pulp fiction reservoir dogs
kill bill sexe mensonges et vidéo cinéma
paradiso la leçon de piano
adieu ma concubine la cité de dieu
shakespeare in love game the new york
des aviateurs le patient anglais cdr
scary movie les invasions barbares et
sin city
oui
[Musique]
alors vous arrivés tous les deux de
cannes du festival de cannes vous avez
trouvé comment le festival harvey iphone
fait face tôt je trouvais que le
festival était absolument formidable jeu
les jurys ont fait un excellent choix
bien la seule décision avec laquelle
j'étais pas d'accord que c'était
prennent à la cause que réduites au
meilleur rôle féminin toute seule elle
n'avait pas besoin de tout
tout cet aéropage femina autour d harvey
vous avez déclaré pour moi le meilleur
film réalisé sur los angeles
chinatown de polanski le meilleur film
réalisé sur new york c'est macadam
cowboy de john schlesinger le meilleur
film de gangsters sait il était une fois
en amérique de sergio leone
tous ces réalisateurs sont venues
d'europe
il faut défendre la diversité culturelle
en europe
c'est rare de la part d'un producteur
américain en tant que ça et voyez vous
moi je crois beaucoup à la diversité
culturelle mais en plus il s'agit par le
passé je le répèterai il me semble que
la france et d'autres pays doivent
justement protéger leur cinéma contre
justement le cinéma américain même si
moi je suis américain joue 10 à ross à
main pourquoi parce que les américains
ne rendra honneur aux français n'a pas
été les avec les émissions françaises et
pourtant l'inversé vrai qu'on n'a pas
présenté de films français en tant que
fille ni à la télévision en prime time
depuis 40 ans alors comment où est la
justice où l'équité par rapport aux
français l'onglet mais encore au cinéma
allemand ou espagnol a aucune justice là
dedans moi j'adore le cinéma quand
j'avais 10 ans j'entrais dans un cinéma
chez les voir ce film les 400 coups de
françois truffaut shrek c'était un film
érotique
parce que le titre bull aux forains le
blues la traduction de 400 coups ça
faisait penser au blowjobs au pipe
alors on a fait quatre des kilomètres
sous la neige pour les voir ce film il
ya que mon frère et moi qui avons vu ce
film parce que tout le monde était déçu
c'est un film en noir et blanc avec les
sous titres pas une seule vie enfin
toujours est il que huit de mes copains
ont quitté le cinéma en cours en disant
allez vous faire voir les pubs et moi on
est resté et on est tombé amoureux du
cinéma français ce jour-là à l'âge de 10
ans avec le film de truffaut riz c'est
une mission d'amour de considérer dans
la banlieue de new york
votre père s'appelait max il était déjà
mentaires il vous a mené tous les
samedis au cinéma il aimait tous les
genres sauf les films de guerre parce
qu'ils avaient combattu pendant la
guerre il fallait plus en parler de la
guerre c'est exactement ça en effet mon
frère et moi on adorait les films
d'errol flynn qui sauve l amérique mais
mon père ne pouvait pas supporter c'est
une
de guerre il ya un film qui pour moi à
tout et mystifier s'était il faut sauver
le soldat ryan
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à ce que je
voie ce film je ne comprenais pas ce que
mon père ait zein
mais mon père avait vu justement un de
la guerre il avait participé à des
batailles et c'est pour ça qu'ils
pouvaient pas voir de film de guerre à
moins qu'il ne dise la vérité est très
peu de films d'hollywood de présenter la
réalité on en faisait tout à un film de
propagande autour de la mairie
mais on voyait jamais du sens et les pas
ne tue et jamais personne
ce n'était pas vraiment la vision réelle
de la guerre en votre mère s'appelle
myriam elle est toujours vivante et elle
pense encore que le cinéma est un job
occasionnels et vous dit qu'elle n'a pas
encore perdu espoir que vous deveniez
médecin mais à 81 ans et c'est quelqu'un
a besoin d'une bonne mère juive elle est
là pour ça elle peut vérifier les les
venues aux jeux olympiques pour la
discipline
je me plains de tout et c'était et s'il
ya quelqu'un qui a un souci
elle peut se faire du souci pour tout le
monde en 1979 vous montez avec votre
frère une société qui s'appelle miramax
du nom de vos parents myriam et max
voilà et alors vous allez au festival de
cannes au début des années 80 vous
n'avez pas d'argent vous connaissez
personne et vous êtes dans un placard à
balais à l'hôtel majestic s'était
attaqué à balai et j'ai dormi avec mon
frère parce que sinon il y aurait eu
toutes sortes de rumeurs à mon sujet
personne ne m'a invitée avait filmé dans
le palais des festivals la pétition qui
celle que je suis infiltré comme on
faisait à brooklyn or entrer par les
portes de sortie par les issues de
secours et en os ici j'essaie sur les
sur le marché puis les gendarmes sont
venus le piaggio il faut vous c'est lui
qui était juste à côté de moi qui étais
sur un pc gamer tranquille et c'était
c'était sean connery en personne qui
nous aider j'en ai alors dit à cet
effort monsieur bond a dit bon nous on
les sait rester dans la salle et c'était
la première fois que j'ai rencontré sean
connery et 20 ans plus tard j'ai raconté
cette histoire
lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur de lui
présenter un film dans le cadre du film
festival de new york et je suis raconté
l'anecdote il a beaucoup ri parce que
c'est le genre de personne qu'il aime le
cinéma tronquée alors voilà donc en 1981
arrive in sync et son premier festival
de cannes et dix ans plus tard dans un
autre festival de sundance organisé par
robert redford
vous repérez sexe mensonges et vidéo des
soderbergh et c'est le début du succès
vous inventez le blockbuster sur le film
qui marche indépendants isv oui je sais
pas si j'ai inventé ce ce genre moi il
me semble que un grand film a besoin
d'être confiné aux ghettos des films
d'art et essai sexe mensonges et vidéo
on peut le voir dans le monde entier
il fallait pas le confiner aux petites
salles le fait qu'un film soit
intelligent ne signifiait pas qu'il soit
limité
c'est les mauvais films qui devraient
être limitées mais les films
intelligents devrait avoir un large
public au contraire oui alors votre
autre grande spécialité harvey c'est la
course aux oscars
vous dépenser des millions de dollars en
publicité en soirée spéciale en cadeau
sans parler des coups de fil avec un
acharnement au delà du réel pour avoir
des oscars vous promettez aux acteurs
que citera avec vous ils vont avoir la
petite statuette dorée qui est 250
domination va se jouer à quelques
soixante et onze oscars
ap alors oui ça l'est pour moi
l'académie les oscars c'est la façon de
commercialiser un rhum finance donc
évidemment on a investi beaucoup de
temps et d'efforts là dedans mais
quelquefois il ya un petit film comme le
son piano ou shakespeare in love ou le
patient mais n'auraient normalement pas
trouvé un grand public à travers le
monde mais c'est évidemment l'oscar qui
était le tremplin qui leur a permis
d'abord sur la table alors pas
simplement pas nécessairement meilleur
film mais aussi mon meilleur rôle
masculin au féminin
évidemment ça aide énormément un film
l'année prochaine hors vous avez
d'afrique à jouer brian pothier qui a
joué cap j'ai vu 20 minutes de ce film à
cannes et sa prestation je suis sûr
qu'elle mériterait un oscar en tout cas
elle sera nominée cotillard dans la vie
devient le piaf ont réalisé par olivier
dahan est produit par ilan goldman alors
on vous reproche quand même harvey un
certain irrespect pour les oeuvres ont
dit que vous coupez que vous remontez
les films les français dit vous vous
appelle d'artagnan à cause du sabre et
on vous appelle aussi six organs harvey
s'est voué à une guerre des chefs de
chaleur après l'émission
je vais vous montrer la version de cinq
heures de game the new york et vous
comprendrez mec
et s'il vous arrivait à tenir trois
heures un chapeau a le plus grand
honneur que j'ai reçu c'est que martin
scorsese dit maintenant que les la
version de deux heures et demie est la
seule verso qu'il présentera donc lui on
est contents il n'y a que la concurrence
qui m'accusent d'être crn ce parce
qu'ils sont jaloux mais nous nous misons
la vérité et en disant la vérité en face
nous emportons les palmes dans les
oscars il a l'habitude de dire la vérité
alors c'est vrai pour un metteur en
scène quand on lui dit son film est long
c'est difficile c'est difficile et les
metteurs en scène sont entourés de
collaborateurs qui n'osent pas paris est
un peu brusque mais souvent essentiels
alors il faut c'est bien plus encore aux
états unis vous savez conteste les films
sur des publics cliniques privées
hosting preview avant de les sortir et
on apprend beaucoup et malheureusement
il a souvent raison c'est à dire que la
conclusion du public c'est un peu ce qui
l'a anticipé mais il le fait à la fin
avec la collaboration des metteurs en
scène des producteurs est ce que est ce
que patrice chéreau est content de la
version courte de la reine margot vous
avez distribué aux états unis qu'il en
est très satisfait et hamilton
je crois que la seule chose qui a
empêché le film d'être un peu plus
grands succès encore c'est que john
était censé tenir en amérique pour faire
la promotion
or elle avait des problèmes personnels
l'a pas dit mais c'était là c'était une
déception que sa peine ne puisse pas
venir mais toutes les critiques étaient
très bonne sur la reine margot et on
estime que c'est l'un des grands films
français les états unis et c'est la
version courte mélodie
ils étaient très contents de voir ce
film pour lui en tant que juif y trouvez
que c'est un soulagement de voir des
protestants des cats a dit qu'ils se
tuent entre eux plutôt que d'avoir des
des juifs qui se font assassiner c'était
un fils très relaxant alors on vous
reproche aussi d'être terriblement dur
en affaire harvey il ya une phrase qui
courent sur vous à hollywood qui dit si
vous ne vous êtes jamais fait baiser par
miramax si vous n'avez jamais travaillé
avec eux eyepet hommes et leur game
heroes alors là encore ceux qui disent
ça généralement se cachent derrière
l'anonymat
ce qui est bien souvent ce sont des gens
qui n'ont pas de succès est-ce que vous
avez le nom de l'auteur de cette
citation n'y a que les lâches qui diront
des choses pareilles en 1993 ou vendent
et donc à disney la société miramax ce
qui s'est passé
c'est que tous les metteurs en scène
découvrait tout le temps mais nous
n'avions pas les moyens
malgré notre succès nous n'étions qu'en
même temps une petite maison de
production donc plein champ qui a
réalisé my left foot nous a quittés pour
aller à une berceau parce que nous y
opposer mieux alors évidemment on aurait
proposé davantage si vous n'avez pu mais
nous ne pouvions pas d'eau quand nous
nous sommes vendu à disney ils ont
décidé de nous donner les moyens de
travailler avec ces réalisateurs
isautier très bien au départ des sept
premières années de la collaboration
avec disney ont été excellentes on a
fait pour fonctionner ils se sont un peu
mêler de ça mais disons que on pouvait
naviguer assez bien et on a fait tourner
sporting a fait beaucoup de films très
controversé mais après documents et
fahrenheit nine eleven où ils ont refusé
londres 12 miles bon là ça a commencé à
mal tourner disney vous a refusé le
seigneur des anneaux j'avais développé
un projet avec peter jackson
j'ai mis 10 millions de dollars pour
développer toute la technologie d
chômage en nouvelle-zélande pour pouvoir
faire ce que vous avez vu à l'écran les
trois scénarios ont été développés par
nous je les voir dès ce jeudi puis le
jackson ou faire trois films il nous
faut 180 millions $ parce que j'avais un
plafond je pouvais pas aller au delà de
75 millions c'est tout ce que je peux
dépenser quand j'étais aux commandes et
j'aurais dit il m'en faut plus je
voulais faire trois ont dit non non
seulement on n'y croyait pas seigneur
des anneaux mais ils m'ont dit je
conserverai une partie des recettes en
tant que producteur veut garder des sous
qu'est-ce que vous n'y croyez pas et
c'est comme ça que font qu'on sera
franchie donc ça plus faranah et les
films de michael moore vous avez quittez
donc votre association avec disney ils
ont produit fahrenheit qui a gagné à
cannes
michael moore et disney a refusé de le
distribuer parce que il attaqué bien sûr
le président bush son frère et lui ont
sorti un chèque ont payé le film l'ont
acheté
quelle erreur pour disney et l'on
distribue dans le monde entier avec le
succès que vous connaissez courageux
alors que l'écouté donc votre
association avec disney et vous avez
monté une nouvelle société qui s'appelle
the weinstein company vous disposez d'un
milliard de dollars donc ça laisse
rêveur soit pour faire des films
ils ont un milliard de dollars évitant
le cinéma ils seront lever un milliard
de dollars donc associé avec tarak ben
ammar c'est assez beau d'ailleurs de
voir le juif de brooklyn qui était
associé avec le le musulman de de tunis
c'est assez joli l'histoire 1 c'est la
bible c'est la bible avec vous il ya des
français il ya des européens il ya tf1
il ya patrick le lay qui est associé
avec vous il ya lvmh aussi qui est
associé avec vous c'était ces voix là
c'est assez cuménique finalement des
japonais un chinois un c'est vraiment
une compagnie internationale est très
européenne tout en étant américaine avec
borbé ravis qu'ils détiennent 50% de la
compagnie 50 ou 51 51
or voilà donc parmi les premiers films
de cette société il y en a un qui
s'appelle liang hannibal le jeune animal
qui est un puits quell de la fameuse
série du silence des agneaux avec
gaspard ulliel alors c'est très gonflé
d'avoir pris gaspard ulliel
mais ça c'est la dp2 taquin c'est lui
qui l'a découvert bien sur le terrain
qu'en tant que producteur du film
l'année dernière à cannes m'a présenté
un casting avec la smart as cinq minutes
de questions qu'ils avaient été tous les
acteurs américains et plus quand nous
voulait se roule j'ai vu ce casting
c'est absolument extraordinaire ce
garçon ira très très loin il est rien
car nation d anthony hopkins
mais le courage de rares vie c'est de
confier parce que le film sortira dans
3500 salles le 9 février aux états unis
dans le monde entier
c'est la première fois qu'un budget de
cette importance est confié un jeune
acteur français absolue ça c'est gaz par
leur compagnie ouais même avec le test
de gaz par ul
n'auraient pas suivi parce qu'ils
auraient dit comment on va le promouvoir
un service et comment le promouvoir
et pour l'histoire naturellement c'est
pourquoi anthony hopkins est devenu un
électeur donc c'est la vie du jeune
hannibal et on expliquera on ne dira pas
ici pourquoi il est devenu moi je le
sais bien
alors vie tarak nous a dit tout à
l'heure que vous disiez toujours la
vérité donc on va voir on va faire une
interview hollywood swiss haye
entre basique in sting t2 et
marie-antoinette lequel vous détestez le
plus tout ça c'est le le plus horrible
des deux c'est incroyablement mauvais
rien antoinette a quand même des très
bonnes choses de daube mais qu'est-ce
que sofia coppola doit encore apprendre
à sofia coppola est une belle la
réalisatrice elle avait cette vision la
critique n'a pas suivi mais le public
semble l'avoir suivie jusque au mans
mais le fait de comparer marie
antoinette est basée à 5 2 des plus
mauvais films jamais réalisés
au-delà du pire si vous voyez ce film
l'argent devrait aller vous voulez à
part ça ça m'a bien plu ah oui qu'est ce
que vous n'aimez pas à hollywood
allez vous êtes un club fermé
moi je me suis dit ce serait tout comme
rome à l'époque ancienne
il fallait être spartacus en quelque
sorte pour déclencher une révolte que
vous avez les grosses médor et si gros
studios qui sont identiques mais qu'un
mois s'intéressent davantage à l'argent
ce n'est qu'une question d'argent de
grossesse ou alors si les gens disent
qu'on est dur c'est eux qui nous ont
raccourci cd studio qui nous ont endurci
et le fait qu'on soit sûr c'est ça qui
nous a permis de les combattre parce
qu'attention avant lui personne ne
pouvait rivaliser avec les idiots des
petits réalisateur et se dessiner à se
sont écrasés maintenant ils ont plus de
pouvoir lâcher parce que nous avons été
dur quel est l'acteur hollywood qui
mérite plus 20 millions de dollars par
film
la plupart dont
qu'est ce que les français font mieux
que les américains au cinéma français
ont un cinéma plus intime plus personnel
le spectateur voit son intelligence
flatté c'est les acteurs sont
intelligents le personnage de scénario
et c'est d'être à tes jambes et on n'est
pas condescendant par rapport au public
c'est dire qu'on relève le niveau alors
calmez vous pour attirer un maximum de
public on nivelle par le bas alors que
en france ma tendance à d'étendre notre
sens et les comédiens sont récurrents en
général j'ai vraiment eu copie les
comédies françaises
weber ou des hommes et grands
comme ils ont leur eau leur copie tout à
hollywood avant ces longs gaz au film ma
[ __ ] manier bonne qu on va te payer
gelée difficile chez moi j'ai un peu
envie qu est-ce qui vous a énervé
récemment chez tom cruise je connais en
fait c'est sa religion orthodoxe et
c'est tout match elle thomas était un
petit peu étroit d'esprit c'est
quelqu'un de très sympa que je connais
très bien
on a vécu quand même il meurt pendant
longtemps une sur les amis mais je crois
qu'il a pris peur fermé mais il va se
rouvrir je pense dans les années à venir
c'est ce que je pense sinon vous pouvoir
de film sur ma production m'enfin c'est
un très bon oeil à gaspard car et vous
qu'est-ce que n'importe quelle actrice a
de plus que nicole kidman
moi j'ai fait sept films avec nicole
kidman y compris le film pour lequel
elle renonce car c'est une idée
absolument ex trader extraordinaire sur
tous ses aspects les films comiques
sérieux nicole kidman et tout astucieuse
accepté 15 millions $ d'un studio
et puis lui normal travaillent
gratuitement sur ds que je fais avec
elle ou encore une fois sur un petit
projet elle est très généreuse qu'elle
filme avez vous regretté de produire
être prêt à porter avec robert altman
mon problème c'est que j'ai jamais
rencontré marché de masse très ami avec
ce trailer end à l'infini et j'ai oublié
de faire mon job de producteurs j'ai
passé mon temps avec 27 au toute la
journée jeux la compagnie du matin au
soir il m'a emmené à déjeuner il me
racontait toutes les anecdotes sur
fellini des sica et
tous les ses héros de mon enfance et
pendant huit semaines j'ai oublié mon
travail alors robert lemay 2010 mais je
te vois jamais tu passes tout autant
avec marcello alors je n'ai pas pu
vraiment participer au film
[Musique]
mais
tant que parent pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu